[Music]
from the guy who wrote some of your
favorite action movies
and the company who made some of your
favorite video games
comes what hollywood execs call synergy
audiences call
garbage and true cinephiles call an
unintentional comedy masterpiece
i'm gonna get on my boat and i'm going
upriver
and i'm going to kick that son of a
bison's ass so
hard
[Applause]
street fighter the movie
one year after the super mario bros
spaghetti face their way into theaters
comes another big whiff at a game
adaptation as the franchise about
one-on-one fights
gets turned into a sprawling war epic
but most of the budget went to getting
jean-claude van damme
and most of his budget went to getting
cocaine leaving nothing left for
competent martial artists
or cool special effects
forcing raul julia to turn in the best
final performance
in the least deserving movie since orson
welles played unicron
you cannot destroy my
gesture
[Music]
meet colonel guile an american hit in
the head so many times
he went full belgian this is the
collection agency bison
your ass is six months overdue and it's
mine
he may be missing his character's
trademark flat top and
powers but at least they managed to
include guile's famous invisible rocket
boat
wait was that oh i'm sorry he didn't
have an invisible rocket boat in the
game
that was just something he thought about
cocaine that makes sense he'll lead a
fantasy version of the u.n
that can do more than write strongly
worded memos
but when those peace-loving bureaucrats
get in the way of a good fight
he'll heroically stage a military coup
of a sovereign nation
council stop them please i would love to
but some just scanned me
huh i guess he really is american are
you meant enough to fight with me
watch as raul julia battles cancer and a
terrible script to deliver an all-time
great villain performance
for you the day bison graced your
village
was the most important day of your life
but for me it was tuesday with more
charisma in his cape than the rest of
the cast
and the good stuff ends there as the
movie goes out of its way
to focus on the street fighters day jobs
you got paid like chun li
reporter dolce lab worker
e honda van driver balrog
cameraman dj it guy
cami kylie minogue and canon ryu
schmucks maybe a couple of hustlers can
help have a think of
endless thing then interrupts her cuts
away from nearly every single fight
before it really gets going
[Applause]
[Music]
you're all under arrest look no one's
expecting you to do the bonus stage
where you fight a car or whatever but
could you maybe put some street fights
in your street fighter movie you had one
job
so strap in for a film that by any other
name could have been a cult 90s comedy
but instead turned a beloved game into a
terrible movie
that somehow got turned into a terrible
game
but someday some filmmaker will finally
get the street fighter experience right
to reuse shooting hadoukens at each
other until one runs out of quarters and
gets a nosebleed
game over
starring atomic blonde are we the
baddies
the guy capcom picked to play ryu but
his english was so bad they recast him
as a random soldier they keep cutting to
for no reason
a single boat against everything he's
got the pilot
would have to be out of his mind if it
bleeds it chun leads
dave coulier i can't get you out of my
head cannon
look he's indian close enough references
to better movies
come out from behind the curtain wizard
good
[Music]
morning tender greens the braid
redemption vega genesis
senior uppercut colossus and
john claude van damme's famous splits
seriously
what a ripoff they go see a jcbd flick i
want to see some splits
just give me the splits from time cop
then have a nice day
[Music]
that'll do
one good thing about this movie it paved
the way for chris klein and legend of
chun li
you don't want a ticket to this dance
detective you just inherited a big
problem
and i've tracked him through 11 major
cities on four continents and never come
close
not once this guy walks through the
raindrops
every line a poem nash
hadouken a duke into your face the thing
about street bites
the street always wins i will eat your
jelly beans
i swear by my pretty floral bonnet i
will end you
dunder mifflin this is pam pizza time